hallo Leute hier ist wieder eure Meinung
und willkommen zu einem neuen Testvideo
hier live aus Korea aus unserem
Hotelzimmer heute testen wir Produkte
von seven eleven das ist ein Minimarkt
du sagst auf jeden Fall Google und
dieser Minimarkt ist zu vergleichen mit
Spar oder Rewe to go man bekommt da
einerseits Getränke und Snacks wie Chips
oder Süßigkeiten aber auch warme
Gerichte oder Gerichte die man sich zu
Hause warm machen kann und da die
meisten von euch so wie ich
wahrscheinlich auch früher vor meiner
kurierreise keine Ahnung davon hatten
was ist da so gibt habe ich mal ein paar
Produkte eingekauft um sie zu zeigen und
gemeinsam zu testen let's go ist hier
seven eleven drauf ja ich hoffe ihr habt
ein bisschen Zeit mitgebracht denn das
dauert hier ein bisschen eine Sache die
ich euch schon im Korea Block gezeigt
habe ist dieser
Eisbecher also ein Becher gefüllt mit
Eis den kann man in jedem Minimarkt
eigentlich kaufen und sich ein Getränk
reinmachen so to go ist also ein Becher
wie man den beim Starbucks oder ein
Bubble Tea Laden bekommt es gibt eine
riesen Auswahl an Getränken die man da
rein machen kann Kaffee Limonade
isotonische Drinks ich habe mich für
Grapefruit
ein bisschen aufgeregt Leute es ist
lange her dass ich gefilmt habe ich habe
mich für Granatapfel Geschmack
entschieden und hier kann man sicher
sein wenn
da genau da drin steckt dafür nehme ich
mir ganz einfach meine google übersetzer
App und dann halte ich das einfach so
aufs Produkt drauf und dann übersetze es
mir in der App kennt ihr wahrscheinlich
schon ich finde es super praktisch die
Übersetzung ist manchmal so gut Granada
will voller Frische erfrischende und
duftende granatapfel-eight es ist eine
frucht-aid die mit Granatapfel überall
einem süßen sauren Duft leicht genossen
werden kann wir Konzentrat 1,1%, aber
100% Granatapfel und 50 kann nicht
singen ja das ist sehr viel was ist da
so drin ja wasserzucker Zitronensäure
irgendwelche Glycerin Eisessig Alkohol
also nicht wirklich Alkohol aber ich
glaube ja Alkohol und dann seid ihr
unterwegs nehmt euch euren Becher
den Geschmack den ihr haben wollt und
ganz vorsichtig oh nein
und schon habt ihr eure Grapefruit
Limonade so und dann nehmt ihr den
Strohhalm von Timos Kaffee
Mix hier einmal schön durch und genießt
euer Getränk
UI sehr süß also für mein persönlichen
Geschmack
darf es nicht so süß sein
ich würde eher immer mit Wasser mischen
übers Plastik muss man nicht sprechen
ich wollte einfach nur mal zeigen als
nächstes habe ich euch ein unigieri
mitgebracht und das kennt man aus einem
Rewe Supermarkt z.B oder Lidl die
Geschmacksrichtungen gibt es in Kimchi
im Thunfisch Fleisch Bulgogi und ich
habe glaube ich ein vegetarisches ah
sorry es ist nicht ein unigieri ein
unigiri wäre es in Japan hier ist es ein
dreieckiges gimbap lecker ohne Fleisch
in den Inhaltsstoffen schreiben Sie auch
immer woher was kommt also z.B das
Weizenmehl hergestellt in USA und
Australien die Gewürze in China Bohnen
aus Taiwan und das Sonnenblumenöl aus
Spanien ja also lecker ohne Fleisch und
dann findet man es hier
[Musik]
und ich komme nicht dahinter das könnt
ihr gerne in die Kommentare schreiben
wie sie es schaffen
das es hat immer geklappt wenn ich
selber gekauft habe immer also das ist
so eine grandiose Technik das ist
sesamblatt erst jetzt das den Reis
berührt also ihr seht hier ist dann so
rot da drin und man sieht das hässlich
aus Scheiße das ist ein Reis Dreieck
Gemüse
das ist einfach der perfekte Snack wenn
ich sowas früher in der Schule gehabt
hätte interessieren Reis der macht dich
satt dann ist da so eine geile Kimchi
Tomatensoße dann sind wir vielleicht
noch ein paar Sojabohnen drin das sieht
dann Blatt und das ist doch viel besser
als so ein Käsebrot zehn von zehn als
nächstes testen wir Hot Dog ich habe
sicher falsch ausgesprochen aber als ich
hier ankam habe ich zu einem Jan gesagt
ich möchte gerne Hotdog Essen und sie
hat gesagt echt ich liebe Hot Dog dann
hat sie mir auf dem Markt Hot Dog
gezeigt und es war das hier ich brauche
aber von diesem Hot Dog mit Pommes
irgendwie am Spieß aber das hier heißt
auch hot Talk aber es wird anders
geschrieben und ich hatte ach jetzt ist
Honig jetzt versteht er Honig oder
hergestellt mit lokaler Hilfe es ist
weich und feucht mit
ein einem leichten Hot Dog der im Ofen
gebacken wird quasi eingefüllter
Pfannkuchen probieren wir mal ne ich
habe ein Hotdog auf dem Markt probiert
der
war lecker jetzt aber nicht mein
Favorite der sieht natürlich ein
bisschen anders aus hatak ich spreche es
falsch aus
[Musik]
ist es lecker so eine Art Gebäck der in
den Toaster nice der Honig schmeckt kein
bisschen wie Honig es ist einfach süß
ist einfach eine geile Kombi hat doch
nicht zu verwechseln mit
Hot Dog unser nächstes Produkt ist auch
so eine Art Rahmen also was man mit
heißem ist es was muss man das
vielleicht nur in den Ofen packen oh ich
glaube ich verblüht okay aber was ich
euch schon was zeigen kann hier packen
sie überall Gesichter drauf von
bekannten Leuten also wenn du jemand
bist wirst du safe in deinem Leben ein
Produkt in der Hand halten und Lächeln
in wirklich jedem Produkt auch auf
Nudeln boah was kommen hier für ein ganz
[Musik]
ein Löffel den man sich selber
zusammenbauen kann wird es passte und Öl
und das macht man ja gut das können wir
nicht essen das macht man sich im Ofen
warm in der Mikrowelle hier in unserem
Hotel Frühstück das als Porridge
verkauft also Reis der sehr lange
gekocht wird und dann weich ist ich habe
ja die Mulan Reissuppe in meinen
Kochbuch eingepackt und ich denke es ist
zu vergleichen es ist etwas was Koreaner
ganz gerne essen wenn sie sich krank
fühlen weil das einfach den Appetit
einregt schon für den Magen ist und auch
echt lecker schmeckt ja und hier kann
man sich das dann so kaufen dass ich
jetzt aber nicht zubereiten kann dann
machen wir uns jetzt halt was anderes
warm und zwar Rahmen ganz klassisch in
diesem Becher so werden sie hier überall
verkauft denn so kann man sie ganz
schnell essen es ist eigentlich das
praktischste essen wenn man nicht jeden
Tag ausgehen möchte oder viel Geld für
Essen ausgeben will sondern sich einfach
im Hotelzimmer kurz mal was warm macht
es ist keine riesen Portion und man ist
davon wahrscheinlich nicht lange satt
aber ein bisschen erfüllt den Zweck und
das ist jetzt eine Sorte die habe ich
bei 711 gefunden sie heißt seven select
also eine die man nur bei seven eleven
bekommt aber es gibt natürlich auch so
klassische Sorten wie chabagetti und na
ja dieser kleine Panda die Mischung
kennt man übrigens aus pariside und
jetzt gibt's ein kleines Tutorial wie
man das benutzt aufmachen und die
Gewürze rein okay das habe ich noch nie
gesehen das ist glaube ich so Schock
getrocknetes Gemüse und Gewürze und wenn
man zu Hause ist dann kann man sich
natürlich auch schön noch frisches
Gemüse in Ei und sonst was oben drauf
packen um sich seine Rahmen zu pimpen
wir sind aber hier im Hotel zu machen
zum Glück haben wir im Wasserkocher
und dann gebt ihr das heute
in eure Rahmen rein
so eigentlich
werden da kommen ja richtige
diese Schock getrockneten Lauchzwiebeln
die lösen sich gerade hier wieder auf
und werden weich das ist richtig fresh
machen mir die mal Youtube die dürfen
jetzt ziehen und weg
und wieder in der Zwischenzeit
auch noch ein neues Getränk auf dieses
hier das ist ein Getränk und das ist ich
habe ein Anti Kater Video geschaut was
man in Korea also so Anti Kater mäßig
trinkt weil es könnte sein dass wir
einen Abend mal zu viel solch und Bier
hatten und dann habe ich diese Dose
gefunden und es ist sie meinte Birne
Verwendung von Bauchfleisch also
wahrscheinlich Bauchfleisch von der
Frucht ja es ist Birne und Apfel da
steht einmal Apfel da steht einmal Birne
sie hat auch gesagt das ist so ne sieht
aus wie ein Ding was zwischen Apfel und
Birne ist
es ist Birne mit ein bisschen Apfel
schmeckt süß und man hat so ein bisschen
Fruchtfleisch drin leckere Dose zu
trinken
und jetzt können wir auch schon die
Rahmen Essen ich habe das Gefühl
koreanas habe ich im Restaurant
beobachtet wenn sie was richtig lecker
finden und etwas sehen was ihn auch gut
schmeckt oder sie wären sie es probieren
dann machen sie so
also sie ziehen dabei keine Nudeln rein
aber es ist so ein so ein als ob sie
nicht glauben könnten wie lecker gerade
das ist was sie probieren
meistens ist dann auch noch sehr heiß
was Sie essen und dann ist es so ein so
eine Mischung aus ich kann nicht glauben
was ich gerade esse und verdammt ist es
heiß
gestern waren Timo und ich in einer
Cocktailbar und auf der Karte stand zu
essen Rahmen und dann habe ich das
bestellt weil ich dachte ja so ein
kleiner Snack hier ist es sehr normal
dass man zum Trinken auch was ist und
dann haben wir so ein kleines Töpfchen
mit Rahmen bekommen also richtige Rahmen
und das war richtig cool in der Bar zu
sitzen bist du ein paar rahmennudeln
rein zu schlürfen und dabei ein Cocktail
zu trinken komisch fand dass sie nicht
nach 11 Uhr Cocktails ausschenken dürfen
ich bin dann nämlich nach vorne gegangen
habe gesagt hä wo steht denn jetzt hier
noch mal der Moskau Mule weil ich habe
den gar nicht gesehen und dann hat sie
gesagt halt stopp nach 11 Uhr nicht also
Bier und Wein ja und sojo auf jeden Fall
aber Cocktails nicht ah und Whisky auch
kamen gehen halt immer ne und zeigen
sehr geil was gibt es
hier Tisch
Snack Pikachu drauf hier habe ich selber
gar keine Ahnung was ist sein könnte mir
ist aufgefallen dass hier der Turbo
Trend voll im Gange ist man sieht an
jeder Ecken Schokoladen was wir aber bis
jetzt noch nicht gefunden haben ist Hot
Dog nicht Hot Dog und was bist du so
safe Turbo
es ist ein schuro ja und wir haben einen
gegessen am Sonntag Tower also der
Fernsehturm das ist so ein hoher Berg
und da steht heute im Fernsehturm drauf
und da gibt es ganz viel zu essen und
man kann da Fotos machen und ein
romantischen
romantisches Schloss an der Brücke
ranmachen und dort haben wir auch einen
so großen Turbo gegessen das war's
Urlaub hat und das Pikachu drauf ist es
auch hier so typisch weil einfach
überall Motive drauf sind es gibt hier
ein Eisladen der heißt Basken Robbins
und es gibt einen Trinkspiel was wir
gespielt haben das habt ihr
wahrscheinlich im Korea Block gesehen
das geht so bestgen Robbins und dann
sagt man thirty one es ist also ich muss
jetzt nicht erklären aber es ist sehr
cool wenn ihr wollt erkläre ich es euch
mal in einem anderen Video na ja und in
diesem Eisladen sind auch gerade Pokémon
als Thema
10 von 10 Pikachu drauf ist es natürlich
nochmal und da habe ich schon ein
dreieckigen brauchen wir natürlich auch
den Classic sagt auf keinen Fall in
Korea dass es eine sushirolle ist weil
das ist was ganz ganz anderes das kann
man hier an jeder Ecke kaufen und ist
das perfekte Picknick food oder Lunch
was du dir so mitnehmen kannst dass du
halt schnell snacken kannst wenn du ein
Ausflug machst machst du dir kimbab und
ich bin zu blöd ist auszupacken da
gibt's natürlich auch wieder 100
verschiedene Geschmacksrichtungen womit
sie so gefüllt sein können ich glaube
wenn ihr schon mal Sushi selbst gemacht
habt dann könnt ihr das auch selber
der Hersteller dieser Rolle heißt Lotte
und Lotte gehört hier alles es gibt
Lotte Hotels Lotte Wohnhäuser Lotte
Getränke Lotte Essen Lotte Ria das ist
dann fast Food Kette es gibt eine Firma
der gehört hier alles auch das
hmm das ist scharf angebratenes Fleisch
ich glaube mit Surimi reddish Karotten
und irgendwie grün Blatt und dann
natürlich mit einem Seetang drumherum
und Reis am Rand aber ist kein Sushi
[Musik]
jetzt ist aber wieder mal Zeit etwas
Süßes die Klimaanlagen hier machen mich
fertig man muss wirklich auch ins warmen
draußen ist immer so eine Jacke oder ein
Pulli mitnehmen weil sobald du in einen
Laden reingehst
ist es so kalt dass du dich warm
anziehen musst ich gucke immer auf die
Klima aber auf was sie dir gestellt
haben 18 Grad wenn es draußen 34 sind es
ist unfassbar also Süßkram habe ich hier
allgemein noch nicht wirklich probiert
und das ist jetzt ein
cranky ach ja und von wem ist kranki
natürlich von Lotte ach so und morgen
fahren wir zum Lotte Tower und Lotte
world ein Vergnügungspark und der Lotte
Tower ist das größte Gebäude hier im Zoo
wenn ich in der koreanischen Drama Serie
leben könnte dann würde ich in der Leben
in der der Lotte Sohn sich in mich
verliebt also timo ist natürlich in
einem tragischen Unfall gestorben und
ich habe lange um ihn getrauert und er
hat mir aber immer wieder beteuert wenn
er mal nicht da ist soll ich schnell
weitermachen und dann kommt der Sohn vom
Lotte Imperium verliebt sich in mich
aber ich kann natürlich am Anfang nicht
weil du da bist also nicht mehr aber du
warst mal in meinem Leben und aber er
überzeugt mich davon dass eine zweite
Liebe wirklich ist guten Appetit
bist
nicht so lecker glaub das ist nicht so
lecker weil es nicht so süß ist muss
nicht sein also wegen der Schokolade
würde ich hier nicht noch mal herkommen
ich freue mich so das ist auch von Lotte
oh ja wenn ich sage alles gehört Lotte
alles gehört Lotte ja hier haben wir
einen großen rote Bohnen Ring Bagel und
ich liebe rote Bohnen deswegen glaube
ich dass ich das hier aufnehmen
oh ist das lecker ah ist das lecker oh
mein Gott ich muss sofort zurück und
dann ist es haltbar bis zum 28.06 22
sehe ich das richtig boah das hält sich
nicht so lange was für lecker das ist oh
mein Gott das ist lecker genauso was
habe ich gesucht das ist ein weicher
briocheartiger Teig mit einer richtig
dicken fetten Schicht rote Bohnenpaste
drin den perfektes Sandwich die ich so
schön aktiv richtig Geld kommen wir zu
unserem letzten Produkt nein das Ding
kann nicht vibrieren das ist ein
anti-kater Drink ihr kennt
wahrscheinlich alle mittlerweile die
Sage um elotrans das ist den Kater nicht
so stark machen soll die verkaufen hier
in so vielen Variationen Anti Kater
Drink weil man muss es leider sagen
dieses Land wirklich starkes
Alkoholproblem hat die saufen hier das
solju und Bier sie ist so toll Weg Timo
und ich sehen regelmäßig Leute die hier
schwanken durch die Straße laufen am
ersten Abend als wir mal rausgegangen
sind und dann so um 2 Uhr nachts zu
unserem Hotel verlassen ist ein Mädchen
schreien uns vorbei gelaufen hat sich
vor uns hingesetzt ist nach hinten
umgefallen und dann kam ihr betrunkener
Freund hat ihr hochgeholfen woanders
sind die zusammen weg und wir saßen da
und waren so wow es ist
Dienstag wir befinden uns aber auch in
Hong Day und Hong Day ist eine Studenten
Gegend also hier leben viele Studenten
und gehen dann natürlich dementsprechend
auch saufen ich glaube so du ist der
meistverkaufte Alkohol in der ganzen
Welt und das muss was heißen Russland
ist nämlich sehr groß und Wodka trinken
sehr viele Leute aber die Koreaner sagen
und dann ist es auch mal vorgekommen
dass wir ein bisschen sowieso du
getrunken haben und ja so ein Anti Kater
Drink danach gekauft haben ich weiß
nicht ob der hilft aber er sieht gut aus
und schmecken tut er nicht schlecht ein
bisschen wie Medizin aus
schmeckt auch schlechter als ich in
Erinnerung hatte ja ich hoffe euch hat
das Video gefallen es war jetzt
natürlich mit ein bisschen mehr
Anekdoten und Geschichten hier aus Korea
aber ich war ganz happy mal euch
persönlich was davon erzählen zu können
und mein Lieblingsprodukt heute ist
natürlich der rote Boden ich bin Schock
verliebt und der gimbab also der
dreieckige tolle Produkte alleine dafür
würde ich immer zurück nach Korea Reisen
und ich hoffe ihr tut das auch
irgendwann mal und falls es euer
Lebensraum ist hier mal her zu fliegen
hoffe ich ganz fest für euch dass er
sich erfüllt denn es ist wirklich sehr
cool hier sehr cool bis zum nächsten Mal
ciao
ah nee nee nee nee nee nee nee sorry ich
habe gelernt wenn ich gehe es gibt zwei
Sorten tschüss erstens das tschüss ich
gehe und das tschüss jemand anderes geht
von dir weg und da ich jetzt gehe ich an
Jungs
tschüss
[Musik]